STACIE CHAN: Good
morning, everyone.
Welcome to another
Media Talks at Google.
The Google News
team, Richard and I,
are so excited to bring in
another incredibly innovative
entrepreneur in
the digital space.
Steven Levy is the
editor-in-chief of Medium.
And with that, let's
welcome Steven Levy.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD GRINGAS:
And thanks, Stacey.
I actually need to give
a shout out to Stacie,
because she's done a great job
putting this series together.
And we'll be doing quite a
bit more as we go forward
because we have such, I
think, great opportunities
to bring interesting people
to come talk to us at Google.
So Stacie does
all the hard work,
and I just get to sit up
here and talk to folks.
So thank you for that.
So Steven Levy has been
writing about Silicon Valley,
like, before there was a
Silicon Valley, a long time.
Without question one
of the most prominent,
if not the most prominent,
and prolific tech
writers of our generation.
He's written seven
books about everything
from cryptology, to Apple--
couple of books about Apple.
And, of course,
one significant one
about Google, which with that
2011 book, "In The Plex,"
I think is generally considered
to be the definitive book
about Google.
And Larry and Sergey gave
you unprecedented access,
and the result was a really
superb work on your part.
And we thank you for that.
Of course, he's
written extensively
about Apple over the years.
Besides those books, his
obituary on Steve when he died
was the most-read story ever
on Wired.com, not surprisingly.
Now Steven is at Medium, as
editor-in-chief of Medium,
and also created their
tech-focused Backchannel.
And then we'll be talking about
some of that today as well.
So, as usual, I'm going to start
off with maybe half a dozen
or so questions,
and then we're going
to open it up to the Dory
and the folks in this room.
So, get your thoughts together.
Given that you have
spent as much time
as you have covering the
sector, covering major companies
and getting deep inside
Google, in looking
at the state of the industry
and the ecosystem today,
what do you think that Google
could do better, compared
to other tech companies?
STEVEN LEVY: Well, first let
me-- thanks to that and thanks
for that great introduction.
I actually should say I'm the
editor-in-chief of Backchannel,
not all of Medium.
I don't think Medium
has an editor-in-chief.
But thanks for the kind words,
and it's great to be here.
I'm going to say
something that I
think Google's been doing a
better job of over the years
but still can do better at,
and that's transparency.
I think that a lot of the
issues that Google finds itself
mired in, a lot
of the suspicions
that people have about
Google, could be mitigated
with even more openness.
I found Google, when I
looked into it, as sort
of like a lobster.
It was sort of like
crusty on the outside.
It was hard for an
outsider, generally,
to know what was going on.
But in the inside, it
was all soft and mushy.
Everyone in Google knows
what's going on at Google.
Google did a great
job of letting
the people who work there
know what was happening there.
All your internal
communications,
you could look up anyone and
see what they were working on,
which I thought was fantastic.
And giving me access was
sort of something that
was a step that Google took,
which I think helped Google.
And I think that, by and large,
you do see people from Google,
like, interviewed.
But I think you can
go farther than that.
And I think that
the more you share
the way you think with us, the
better off you're going to be.
RICHARD GRINGAS: And I
think that's a valid point.
I've certainly gotten
that criticism many times
from folks who say it's just
too much of a black box--
from publishers who we
work with, and so on.
Now, having said that, I want to
just poke a little bit further,
because I said, "in comparison."
And I'm not looking
for laudates here,
but we look at Apple, of
course, which is profoundly
and notoriously secret.
Facebook, not so sure.
Is anyone--
STEVEN LEVY: A little more open.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Who would
you say is doing it right,
for that matter?
STEVEN LEVY: Well,
I think Facebook
has been more open there.
I haven't talked
to them recently,
but I had a streak where
I was not a stranger
to Mark Zuckerberg's office.
And I wasn't the only
journalist there.
In a sense, they have a
lot of radioactive things
they present to us.
And so they understand that--
talk us to death, really,
and diffuse it there.
You're right.
Apple is super-secretive.
I think they're starting to
come out of that just a little
there.
You're seeing-- it
used to be-- it's sort
of like the opposite of Google.
Google, for a long period,
Larry did-- his interviews
were and still are very rare.
It's not a secret.
It's not his
favorite thing to do.
Whereas Apple, for many
years, the only person
you wind up talking to
would be the CEO, right?
So I had zillions of
conversations with Steve Jobs,
but it was harder
to get conversations
with the people working for him.
He said, "Oh, I don't
want people to hire them
away from me there."
And then there were
some that you would see,
like the marketing people.
To get in with engineers
was really tough.
And I think, Google actually
does a pretty good job of that.
I spent a lot of
time with engineers
and you make them present there.
Some of the other ones, like
I've spent a lot of time
with Twitter.
They're pretty open there.
Microsoft, again, you
could spend a lot of time
with Microsoft.
And I've had zillions
of dives going
through those corridors
of their buildings
there, talking to people there.
You give up something when
you let a journalist in.
It is a very competitive
industry, obviously,
and there are secrets to have.
But generally, I
think by letting
people know what you're doing,
they feel better about you.
RICHARD GRINGAS: I'm going
to switch subjects a bit.
Folks can ask more questions
about your perceptions
of Google if they'd like.
But you're a
technology journalist
who's covered the
tsunami of change
over the last 15, 20 years,
including, obviously,
with the practice and
business of journalism itself.
So, from your perspective,
are you pessimistic?
Optimistic?
What gets you
excited, what gets you
depressed in these transitions?
STEVEN LEVY: I'm
generally optimistic,
though I have my
moments of darkness.
I think that what journalists
and serious journalists
have to offer is so valuable
that they will always
be a call for them.
There's always
going to be, like,
a need for people
to read that stuff.
And get briefed on that.
I think that, consistently,
when a journalist
produces a work of
value, dives into it,
spends days, weeks, months,
working on something
carefully-- you can see
it's carefully vetted
and presented-- there's
always a response.
There's always
appreciation from this.
I see it at Backchannel, which
is the thing that we just
created.
It went live last October there.
Because we didn't have
a built-in audience--
the first really
lengthy story we did
was a story by this woman
named Susan Crawford, who's
an expert on internet
access, and she's
a law professor at
Harvard, but also has
written a couple of books.
She did this really detailed
thing based on data analysis.
Some of them were the
group that actually Google
participated with about how
the Cogent network was being
throttled in some indirect way
by Comcast because of their war
with Netflix.
And it was really complicated.
And it was about a 6,000
word story or something
like that, with charts
and things like that.
And I thought, man who's
going to read this?
Right?
And it became at that time
our most popular story,
our first story really to rise
up well into six figures there.
So, that shows me there's
a huge appetite for this.
On the other hand,
I can't ignore
the depopulated newsrooms, and
that some of the newsrooms that
have sprung up
are full of people
who are rewriting other people's
stories and posting listicles.
I think it was not a
happy moment for me
when I saw the New York Times
run a story a couple weeks ago,
"Five Things You Didn't
Know About Hillary Clinton."
I thought, where did
that come from, right?
I mean, what was the discussion
in the newsroom about that?
So, I worry sometimes.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Well, Let's
go a bit further on that.
I think what's excited
us about the internet,
particularly those
of journalistic bent,
is just how open the environment
is for free expression,
far more open than
any environment we've
had in the history of
civilization, for that matter.
But it's also under threat, in
some ways obvious-- governments
or issues like net
neutrality-- but others
in less and more nuanced ways.
We talk about, for
instance, billions of users
coming online around the world.
But because of data
plans or whatever,
they're using two or three apps
and the web isn't among them.
On mobile, we're frankly seeing
a decline of the mobile web
in terms of time spent.
We're seeing an increase
in walled gardens,
from Facebook to Snapchat and
so on, all of which are sort
of chewing away, theoretically,
at this open environment.
Does that concern you?
Do you have a
perspective to share?
STEVEN LEVY: I think
it is something.
My more parochial concern is
that just the mobile format
is one that doesn't
necessarily welcome
the kind of complex,
long-form articles
that I think are important
to understanding our world.
And I'm still waiting
to see what we come up
with to make up for that.
That's concerning.
But in terms of
the narrowing, it
is a concern because
if just a few apps are
going to be our filters
that all journalists
for all publications have
to take them through,
that's a problem.
I've been watching
with fascination.
I spent a lot of time with
the Facebook News Feed group,
and I've done several
articles about them,
because I think they are
genuinely attempting to balance
what their users see.
And they find
themselves in a position
where for a lot of
their users, they're
curating-- algorithmically,
I guess-- the world of news
that comes through
the news feed there.
And they don't want the
world of news to be trivial,
but they sort of paint
themselves into a corner
by saying, well, what people
click on is what people like.
Right?
And I invented this concept
called the dozen doughnuts
concept that I've
run by them, which
is if you go to work someplace,
and the first day they say,
would you like a dozen doughnuts
delivered to the office?
You're probably going
to say no, because I
am going to put a lot of
weight if someone brings
a dozen doughnuts every day.
But if they just bring
a dozen doughnuts,
you're going to see the
doughnuts are going to be there
and you're going to
eat it there, right?
RICHARD GRINGAS:
Particularly if you chop them
up into bite-size pieces.
STEVEN LEVY: That's right.
Yes, yes.
RICHARD GRINGAS:
Posts in their feed.
STEVEN LEVY: So the
doughnut holes, or whatever,
if they don't really ask
you, they take them there.
They'll see you taking
it, and they'll say,
wow, this guy really
likes doughnuts!
Let's bring more
doughnuts there.
Right?
And that's the way
the News Feed works.
And they have to
get around that.
And they're doing things
now like trying to say,
well, maybe we should
vet some of these stories
to find out they're
not hoaxes and have
them percolate through.
And then a couple of months
ago they said, well, gee,
maybe there's just
too much news.
People aren't seeing news
from their friends anymore.
And then that changes there.
When what is it, 20%,
25%, 30% of the time
people spend on
mobile is Facebook--
is that your
Facebook feed there?
That's an issue there.
And I think it's going to
be tough, because face it.
The publications-- an individual
app, an app for Backchannel,
as opposed to Medium, which of
course has its app-- that would
be tough to compete with space.
And then you have your
Backchannel app, your New
Yorker app, your New York
Times app, your Newsweek,
your everything.
It's going to be
confusing there.
So as we move to this,
we have to figure out
where you can get
your news from a range
of different places,
the same kind of range
you had pre-mobile.
RICHARD GRINGAS: I know
people in this room who
are going to take advantage of
that dozen doughnuts metaphor,
so just make sure to call
"Steven Levy's dozen doughnuts
metaphor."
STEVEN LEVY: I
actually have given
thought to the idea of when
you come up with a meme
and things like that.
And I think I've reached the
Zen state where I have passed
having it attributed to me.
I was the first person to say,
"The Mother of All Demos,"
for the Doug
Engelbart demo there.
And Wikipedia recognized it.
That's all I need, right?
Just like something
you could look it up,
but I don't need to
be cited each time.
RICHARD GRINGAS: No.
My father-in-law wrote the
meme, "I am Spartacus," and--
STEVEN LEVY: Really?
Whoa.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Always
it's amusing, like the,
"Je suis Hebdo."
And I say, wait, credit
where credit is due.
Ain't going to happen.
Let's talk about Medium.
What was your
impetus in joining?
STEVEN LEVY: So I'd been
thinking at that point
last year-- it's a
little over a year ago
that I had this idea-- I
hadn't even actually been
at Medium for a year yet-- that
I'd been working at big news
organizations for 18 years.
I was a freelancer.
I joined Newsweek.
I spent 12 years at Newsweek
when it was really Newsweek.
And then took a buy-out,
like a lot of people
did, and went to
Wired, which sort of
had been an informal home for
me since the thing started.
But it belonged to a big media
organization, Conde Nast.
So that's 18 years during
this time of amazing change
that I was working for
the old guys, right?
And I thought, wow, I'd
like to do something new.
And in a way, a reaction to what
was happening on the internet
there.
Because I saw it even at Wired.
Wired.com ran like 50
stories a day, right?
And a lot of them were just
because they needed stories
there.
The business model was to get
as many page views as possible
and sell ads against them.
And I had an idea that, gee,
what if we did something
that we did a lot fewer stories,
like maybe even just one
day even, and said that was it.
And the idea was that
our competition wouldn't
be these publications in
toto, but the best thing
that those publications does.
So in a given day
on Backchannel,
is my story as good as the best
story in the New York Times
business section,
or on The Verge,
or any of these
other places there?
Would that be a place?
And I'd been looking.
Medium had been coming up
in my feed more and more.
I'd seen a lot of
good stuff on there.
And they had
professional journalists.
They were paying
people to do stuff,
but it wasn't really
so much centered
around publications there.
So I ran into Ev Williams,
who's the CEO of Medium.
And you all know him.
He was here when Google
bought his company Blogger,
which he founded.
And then, of course,
he co-founded Twitter.
And so Medium is his thing.
And I approached him
at Ted over a year ago
and said we should talk.
And we wound up talking, and it
wound up that I found a home.
And also, I was just I
was just hungry to join
one of these internet
companies and experience
what that was like.
I'd visited countless
companies there,
and one of the fun things now
is that there was always a time
when I'd visit the
company, and then I'd leave
and the interesting
things would happen.
They'd go to a
meeting and do stuff
that they wouldn't talk
about to journalists.
And so now I'm in the room
there for the interesting stuff.
RICHARD GRINGAS: And I
think as you're learning,
it's evolutionary,
it's experimentational,
explorational, mean
there's no visible business
model underneath Backchannel.
STEVEN LEVY: Although today,
actually, I have to say
is a special day for me.
It's the first day that
Backchannel has turned a buck.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Really?
STEVEN LEVY: Yes.
We published a story today.
It was sponsored by a company
that used to be Elance,
and they did a series
on the future of work.
We've labeled it clearly as
done in partnership with them.
You can look it up.
It's written by Kevin Maney,
who is a distinguished tech
journalist there.
And we've included it
in Backchannel today.
And tomorrow, we
have another one
that's in partnership
with Samsung,
which is an interview
with Harper Reed telling
what his pivotal moment was
on becoming who he was there.
So Ev is very clear at
saying we can take our time.
He believes building an audience
first, monetization later.
But we thought it was time
to introduce a little revenue
into this world.
RICHARD GRINGAS: And also, as
I think you're experiencing,
being in a startup up
means things change.
STEVEN LEVY: Absolutely.
RICHARD GRINGAS: And
I know recently, there
have been stories of
changes in strategy
at Medium, cutbacks
in certain areas.
Evan made a point in
a post about Medium
not being a publishing
platform but a network.
So is the thinking to become
more of a social platform?
What's going on?
STEVEN LEVY: Right.
So the way Ev explained it
was-- and everyone described
it like he woke up
one day and said,
oh, we have to go
from this to that.
And he pulled up the
data, which is something
he wrote early on, saying that
the things he said in that post
were things that were
always part of the idea
that it was going
to be a network.
So what he wanted
to do, I would say
it's a course correction to
double-down on the network
part of it there.
So the idea was never to
be a big media company,
but to use these publications,
or use the journalistic talent
that he hired, in the service
of building that network there.
And again, that kind of
changes, and experimentation
is one reason why I wanted to
come to a company like that.
So I think we're still
doing Backchannel.
One thing that
you're going to see--
and if you look
carefully, you already
saw it-- is that we're going
to start thinking, well,
what ways can we use journalism
to build our network growth?
So for instance, last
week we did a story
by David Weinberger, who's
the guy who co-invented
the Cluetrain Manifesto.
He's written some fantastic
books on the internet.
And he did a really
interesting thing.
He compared the questions that
a CNN reporter interviewed
Bernie Sanders with after
Senator Sanders declared
himself a candidate
for president,
and then he compared those
to the Reddit AMA questions
that were up-voted.
And he got all the questions
from CNN and all the questions
from Reddit.
And then he concluded
the crowd does a better
job of interviewing a
presidential candidate
than a professional journalist.
And I ran it and changed
that to, please discuss.
And I called up some people I
know-- Jonathan Alter, who's
a former colleague at Newsweek;
Dan Pfeiffer, who actually had
written for Backchannel,
and who used to be,
until recently,
President Obama's Chief
of Communications;
Jay Rosen, who's
one of the best critics
from academia of the press;
Dan Gillmor; Vivian Schiller,
who until recently was
Twitter's media contact.
She'd been at NPR and
the New York Times.
And they responded to it.
And then Craig
Newmark spontaneously
responded with
his comment there.
So we brought this in and made
it more of a conversation.
In a matter of fact,
Jay's comment wound up--
and the way the responses
work on Medium is really nice.
If you keep writing,
it really is
almost like you're posting
something original because it
doesn't stop you, certainly not
at 140 characters, but nowhere.
And he really made
a whole post of it
and we brought it into the
Backchannel collection there.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Since
Weinberg concluded
that the crowd asks
better questions,
I think I'll take
my cue on that one.
STEVEN LEVY: OK.
RICHARD GRINGAS: You
know, interestingly,
since Steven has probably
interviewed some of you,
and if not, many of
your colleagues, it's
our turn now to
poke back at him.
So in the room, if
you've got a question,
we do have a microphone
that we would
ask you to use because we are
recording this, of course.
I'm going to start with
something from the Dory,
and that's a very simple one.
What's your next book?
What are you working on?
STEVEN LEVY: So actually, when
I did this, I had a book in mind
that I put aside.
It was going to be this
massive book about startups.
I don't know if any of you
are familiar with a book
that Richard Ben Cramer,
a fantastic journalist who
tragically died a couple
of years ago, wrote,
called, "What It Takes."
And he did-- I think it was
the 1996 presidential election,
every candidate.
And it was like
an 800-page book.
This was going to be like
"What It Takes" of startups.
And I had cast the
whole thing there.
And I realized I could not
do a thing of that proportion
while I was doing this.
To be honest, I've
never worked harder
than doing this
thing for a startup.
That's what you do.
But I've never had
more fun, either.
Down the road-- and actually,
I think someone else actually
might be doing a book
very much like that now.
So maybe my window
has passed for that.
But there is another idea
I have which I probably
don't want to share now.
But it's probably
a shorter book that
is going to run more
like a narrative there.
RICHARD GRINGAS:
Questions from the room?
AUDIENCE: As an author and an
observer of related industries,
what do you think
about DRM and books?
STEVEN LEVY: Interesting.
I once had a conversation
with Richard Stallman,
who I met when I did my
first book, "Hackers."
This was a more
recent conversation,
where he just went
for 20 minutes
why I should never let Amazon
do one of my books there.
I think, philosophically,
DRM, I see problems with it.
About a year and a
half, my mother died.
She was an avid reader.
She had 750 books
on her Kindle there.
I have her Kindle,
but Amazon won't
let you move it over to yours.
I have to keep her account
alive to keep her books alive.
That strikes me as wrong.
On the other hand, I
will say it's super easy
to copy a book there.
Generally, by and
large, I do generally
think that convenience is the
way to fight piracy as opposed
to DRM.
And I actually do
agree with Jeff Bezos
that-- and there's
been law suits
and things like that--
that selling lots of books
at a lower price is
probably the answer there.
It seems a more attractive
answer to me than DRM.
RICHARD GRINGAS: I'm going to
get back to your-- since again,
you, like me, come from
a different generation.
I mean, computers when I was
in college were punch cards.
I believe you studied
literature in college.
So what triggered your interest
in technology and technology
writing?
STEVEN LEVY: So when I went
to college, you're right.
Literally, they
were punch cards.
We had our courses.
We had to hand in these
punch cards there.
And the computer center was
someplace we'd never visit.
It was walled off.
And I went to grad
school in literature
and realized I wasn't cut out
for me, the work of a scholar.
The teachers made
that clear to me.
So one took pity
on me and gave me
an internship at
the local newspaper
in central Pennsylvania.
At that point, they were
switching from hot type
to cold type, right?
The people working in
the Linotype thing there.
There were some
pretty unhappy people
who used to be master
craftspeople, who were now
pasting down things on boards,
and that was the new wave.
And they were pretty
unhappy and I saw that.
But I loved the
writing part of it
and became a journalist writing
about all kinds of stuff.
I was a rock critic.
I interviewed Bob Marley.
I covered sports
and other stuff.
But in 1981, I got an
assignment to write
about computer hackers.
I did a story for Rolling Stone
about it and it blew my mind.
When I did my research,
the only thing I could find
presented hackers--
this was before there
was any association
with bad behavior.
They were more presented like
booger-stained curiosities,
total losers who couldn't
relate to people.
But when I came out
actually to California here,
I went to Stanford, talked to
other people in the burgeoning
personal computer industry,
the people blew my mind.
They were like explorers.
They were adventurers.
And they were so
excited about this,
and they were onto something.
This was the future there.
And I said, this is what
I have to write about.
And pretty much from that point
on, the bulk of my writing
was about technology.
AUDIENCE: I'm really
curious about you
and what personal attributes
you would attribute
to having done
things that you did,
like find Einstein's brain
when no one else did that,
and how you knew the right
people to interview for hackers
and how you got that so right.
It's fascinating.
STEVEN LEVY: Actually,
it's a great question.
I think there is something in
the personality of a journalist
that is a combination of
curiosity and desperation
which leads us to go on.
Even if our personalities
in cocktail parties
might not be aggressive,
when we're on a story,
you just have to be
aggressive there.
You mentioned the story about
I found Einstein's brain
when I was working for a
magazine in New Jersey.
My editor told me, "Go
find Einstein's brain."
And I actually figured out
who had it, and called up
the guy on the phone.
He hadn't talked to any
reporter for 23 years.
And he didn't want
to talk to me.
But to me, it was like every
story I wrote back then,
I figured, if I didn't
get the story, that's
the end of my career.
So I pushed and pushed until
he agreed to see me there.
So even though I might not
be that way personally,
one-on-one, when I'm on a story,
I still have some of that.
And when I was at
Newsweek, I remember,
it would just
baffle me sometimes.
We would get these interns
from amazing schools.
And you'd say, could
you call up these people
and see what they have
to say about x or y?
And then the next day
you'd talk to them and say,
did you make the call?
And they'd say, yeah,
the line was busy,
or something like that.
And I'd say, what?
What field are you getting in?
So you have to be, I
guess in some degrees,
a little bit of a jerk
to be a journalist.
RICHARD GRINGAS: You say
you push and you push.
I want to push you on that
with regard to technique.
Some of my very closest
friends are journalists,
and it happens to
me time and again
where I find that they get me
to talk about stuff that I had
no intention of talking about.
STEVEN LEVY: Well, I don't mean
you don't have to be pushy--
RICHARD GRINGAS: I
don't mean business.
I mean personal stuff.
STEVEN LEVY: You
could push subtly,
the Colombo kind of approach.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Yeah, exactly.
So come on.
Share a technique or two.
[LAUGHTER]
STEVEN LEVY: OK.
Well, one thing
is-- and this isn't
in a necessarily pushy way.
It seems obvious when
I say it, but actually
if you look at
other journalists,
watch other people do things,
they don't do this enough,
is to ask a direct question.
A lot of times, particularly
when it's a sensitive subject,
people beat around the bush.
Like, "oh, other people
have said," or like,
"I've heard talk that."
Just ask the damn question.
And don't be necessarily
mean about it,
but if you ask a direct
question, especially
when people aren't
even expecting it.
They're almost bracing for you
to sort of beat around the bush
because they know what
you want to ask about.
Ask the question, especially
if it's a question
that you know your readers
want to know, right?
Confront the elephant
in the room right away.
The other side is
that it is true
that just shutting up sometimes
will let the other person fill
the gap there.
And I remember
early in my career,
I'd listen to tapes when
I transcribed there.
And I would sort of
to talk to myself
as I was listening to the tape.
And I would say to
myself, shut up!
Shut up!
You're cutting the person off.
So after listening to
enough of those tapes,
I learned if someone is saying
something, don't stop them.
RICHARD GRINGAS:
Actually, I learned this
in an entirely different
realm of negotiation.
Same thing is let the
pregnant pause last forever
if it needs to.
People will fill
the vacuum, right?
Don't rush in and
change your offer.
STEVEN LEVY: One guy who
that technique doesn't really
work on is Bill Gates.
Bill Gates, he uses
it against you.
I went to his office once.
I did the first story about
the browser wars, right?
Which is another phrase that
Microsoft's PR people said,
you're the first one to
talk about the browser wars.
And I had just
come from Netscape
and went up to Bill
Gates's office.
And my editor from Newsweek
was with me at the time.
He wanted to see what it was
like to interview Bill Gates.
And I started.
I said Bill, I just
came from Netscape
and they're saying
you're doing this.
I outlined the whole
overview of the browser wars,
and so, what do you
have to say about that?
And he just sat
there, and he there.
And, you know, time stopped.
And finally I said, well,
while you're pondering that.
But he got back to it.
He knew.
But you had to confront him.
It was like a little
war of wills there.
And he's got a strong will.
RICHARD GRINGAS:
Well, if I might,
what was the
interaction model-- I
can't believe I used
that phase-- interaction
model with Steve Jobs?
STEVEN LEVY: The
UX for Steve Jobs?
RICHARD GRINGAS: Yes, exactly.
STEVEN LEVY: Totally different.
So when you
interview Bill Gates,
you had to be totally prepared.
If you made the
slightest mistake,
he'd use that as a way to
distract the whole thing
like there.
Like you would make some comment
about the GEM operating system,
and he would say, well
actually, it wasn't that way,
it was this way.
And just take you down this
side road there, right?
So you had to be very careful
when you interviewed him
because he'd always tangle
you in a little dispute there.
So you had sort of know how
to steer the thing around.
Or just open the gap a little.
Because he actually did get to
the questions there and sort of
understand what you needed
there, but you had to earn it.
So Steve Jobs was
a self-starter.
He knew what he
wanted to say to you.
And he would go on.
And so after he did his pitch
and said all the other things,
that was the time
to start asking him
the questions about other stuff.
And I was lucky because I got
to him early in his career.
Later on, it turned
out other journalists
who would ask him
those same questions,
he'd end the interview.
He'd walk out, right?
But I was sort of
grandfathered in
to ask him a challenging
question here and there.
AUDIENCE: So on that subject,
I read your "Insanely Great"
in the mid-'90s.
And then at the end of
the '90s, another book
came out by Michael S. Malone
called "Infinite Loop."
And so it made "Insanely Great"
kind of look like fan fic,
almost.
So how did you react?
Were you aware of
this other book?
STEVEN LEVY: Well, I'll
dispute that fan fic thing.
I think that, basically,
one chapter began,
how the Mac almost failed.
There was a lot of
stories in there,
just the whole story about
Jef Raskin getting booted off
the team.
It was all the stuff you read
in Walter Isaacson's book.
Matter of fact, a lot
of it was taken directly
from "Insanely Great" on there.
So I'll push back
on that, and I'll
stand behind that as the
history the Macintosh,
not to dispute
Malone's reporting.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Steven.
I noticed that you
have worked closely
with generations of
great hackers, inventors,
co-founders,
founders of startups.
Have you noticed any interesting
similarity or dissimilarity
among generations of them?
Technically speaking,
some of them
could be grandfathers
of the younger ones.
STEVEN LEVY: Right.
Well, when I did
"Hackers," it really
was a story of
generations there.
It was my first book.
Again, I was running on
that engine of desperation,
like, they're reading it?
Wow, this really has
to be right there.
And I took on a
pretty ambitious task
to really tell three
different stories there
of three generations
of hackers, beginning
with the very first
hackers, as we know them,
at MIT in the late
'50s early '60s,
and then went to the
home-brew computer club,
and finally it was
what contemporaneously
was happening.
So I was writing the book in the
early '80s, mid-'80s about game
hackers.
And on the 25th
anniversary of the book,
I went and interviewed
some people, some of them
who were in the book
that I followed up on,
but some of them who would
have been in the book
if I had written it 25 years
later, like a Mark Zuckerberg
there.
And I thought it
was interesting.
The one thing that
was really different,
that would have surprised
me when I published
the book in 1984 is
I actually sort of
had a dark outlook that
money you would ruin hacking.
But what happened
was that somehow,
the idea of being a
billionaire became
one which was not in opposition
to being a pure hacker now.
So somehow, they worked it out
where you could be idealistic,
and having all the
riches in the world
wasn't a conflict with that.
They pulled off that
trick, which is--
RICHARD GRINGAS:
Is it fair to say--
I've always thought
this to be true,
but maybe I'm wrong-- that if
I had looked back at earlier
generations of
entrepreneurs, particularly
with regard to the internet,
that most of those folks
came into it with a passion
other than financial.
In fact, most of us
back then didn't really
think that this was
going to be something.
STEVEN LEVY: Right.
RICHARD GRINGAS:
Yet today, it does
seem like there's a much, much
higher proportion of folks
who are coming into
it to pursue wealth.
STEVEN LEVY: Well, but also
the idea is, everyone says,
well, I'm changing the world.
But I do feel that
the idea that you
could be super-wealthy
by pursuing it,
doesn't necessarily mean
that your vision of changing
the world isn't one which
is idealistic, right?
So look at this
company there, right?
Who could be richer
than your founders?
But on the other hand, I do
believe that they pursued this
from the start of their days
of Stanford saying, wow,
we can change the world.
AUDIENCE: As a
writer and journalist
who interacts so closely with
people in the tech industry,
you probably bring a unique
literary and worldly background
into some these discussions.
And I was wondering
if you've noticed
that a lot of
entrepreneurs and CEOs
have very strong opinions
about life, the interactions
of people, maybe religion.
And do you feel like these
engineers and entrepreneurs
have read enough books
or should read more books
or are reading too
many books, basically?
STEVEN LEVY: That's
a great question.
I feel in general, everyone
could read more books.
And it varies.
I mean, some people haven't
read a lot of books.
I think it's fair to say,
in general, that people
who are in their 20s
haven't read as many books
as people who came out
of college in my era
there, particularly when they
have such fascinating things
to occupy their minds
that aren't books
that we didn't have when
we went to college there.
So that isn't necessarily
a criticism there.
Though I do feel--
I guess what I'm
sort of waiting for is
I do believe that you're
more fit to compete if you
have that kind of background
that I think you're referring
to there, of reading books
and getting those
lessons you can only
get from that extensive
concentration in books.
So I'm waiting for the
recognition that that's so.
So the people who
really want to get ahead
are also going to spend a
lot of time reading books
there as an advantage
over their competitors.
AUDIENCE: Venture
capitalism has certainly
changed a lot over the time
that you've been reporting.
And it seems that now, there may
be more motivation financially,
but there's also a
lot more impatience.
If you haven't become a huge
success within 18 months,
well, maybe you
shouldn't be doing this.
How do you see that changing?
And do you see
that as a problem,
or is there a solution to that?
STEVEN LEVY: I think,
look, an entrepreneur knows
what he or she
gets into when they
do VC, when they take VC money.
As it turns out, it's
super-well documented.
The stakes to get in
and build a company now,
what you have to bring
financially to it
are lower than they've
ever been there, right?
So there's a little
more leverage
that the entrepreneur
has over the VCs.
And I think, really, if
you look at the time frame,
though, in the late
'90s, man, people
were going public and
doing things for liquidity
way earlier than they are now.
There's any number of
places that didn't even
have a viable business
plan, let alone
a penny of revenue,
that went public and had
not great outcomes from that.
RICHARD GRINGAS: What did
you think about the situation
with Secret, and not just them.
But as you said,
they're not necessarily
going to the public markets.
But we're in this
interesting arena
now where people are raising
vast amounts of money
against valuations that may
or may not be plausible,
also founders taking
money off the table.
STEVEN LEVY: Well, it's all
to be expected when you're
playing a lottery game, right?
So the VCs, and especially
the seed investors,
will tell you their
model is based
on a couple of hits out of
100, which more than compensate
for the vast majority of
the ones that don't pay off.
So that stuff is
just to be expected.
I think it's a good thing.
I think, really,
it's a positive thing
that we found out all this about
Secret, because now there's
more of a stigma to cashing
out and buying a Ferrari,
and maybe we'll see a
little less of that.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Before we
go to the next question,
I'll pull one from the Dory.
Speaking of writers, which
fiction writers do you think
have the most interesting
insights about technology?
STEVEN LEVY: You
know, Thomas Pynchon
is really on top of stuff.
It was interesting and not
a surprise to me, really,
that his most-recent book was
about Silicon Alley, right?
I actually used a
passage from him
in the epigraph of a book
about artificial life
where he was writing
about something
that seemed to be, to me at
least, about cellular automata.
AUDIENCE: I think you mentioned
that the range of news sources
was getting more limited now
because of mobile devices.
So just wondering,
what do you think
about how mobile
devices and fast news
has affected media in general?
STEVEN LEVY: I don't think
we've seen the full impact yet.
I think there's still
a lot of newsrooms
that are operating at a lag.
It's like the Wile E. Coyote
running past the cliff.
And I guess in
recent years, we've
seen that moment happen
where, whoops, there's
nothing propping
up Wile E. Coyote,
and there's a plummet there.
I think in mobile, we've seen
that moment happen on the web,
but not quite yet
in mobile there.
I don't think we've gotten
the full impact of that format
there, let alone figured
out a way around it.
RICHARD GRINGAS: I
also think that when
we look at patterns of
content consumption today,
people look and say, oh, gee,
it's all about cat videos,
and so on and so forth.
But I sometimes think we've lost
our sense of comparative scale.
Like we see someone like the
Guardian or BuzzFeed with 200,
300 million uniques, as
if, somehow, those folks
are interested, theoretically,
in serious content.
I mean, if you look
back in history,
during the heyday
of mainstream media,
the percentage of
our population who
actually consumed content
from those vehicles
was comparatively small.
STEVEN LEVY: Right.
I mentioned it
before, but I think
it's worth
re-emphasizing that there
is a hunger for well-reported,
well-researched, well-written,
long-form stories.
When I was at Wired, I came
to favor a kind of story
where I'd do a deep dive
into a product right
before it was launched.
And I did one for a couple
Google products there, right?
And people really appreciated
that, as opposed to getting
the quick takes the
day after, or based
on the product announcement
or a briefing the day before.
AUDIENCE: You've reported on
lots of successful startups,
but my question is, what
makes startups fail?
STEVEN LEVY: Well,
there's a lot of things,
but mainly they've misjudged
who is going to like it.
They don't have the
lesson that the people
in the original
Macintosh team had,
saying, build a product
you really want.
Sometimes they'll do
a product and saying,
those people might like
something like that.
But I think that you have
to see if it's really
great to understand it there.
RICHARD GRINGAS:
I do think timing
is a not insignificant factor.
STEVEN LEVY: Oh sure, sure.
RICHARD GRINGAS: And if
you look at the history
of entrepreneurship, how many
ideas that are successful today
were actually surfaced
10, 15 years ago.
Different time,
different circumstances.
STEVEN LEVY: Point well taken.
I did a big story about the
tablet computer, Bill Gates's
and Microsoft's
tablet computer there.
Besides the stylus, which was
not a great idea, and Windows,
which was not a great
idea for a tablet,
it looked a lot like the iPad.
AUDIENCE: So what is the
brightest idea you've ever
had that miserably failed?
STEVEN LEVY: The
brightest idea I ever had?
AUDIENCE: That failed miserably.
STEVEN LEVY: Hmm, interesting.
[LAUGHTER]
I know there were some.
AUDIENCE: You forget about that?
STEVEN LEVY: Hm?
STEVEN LEVY: Yeah.
I don't know.
Nothing, I guess--
clearly the fact
that I haven't been able to
come up with it right away,
even though I know
they're there,
shows that I've probably
gone back and erased it
from my memory there.
I think that at Newsweek, there
were any number of dead ends
that I pursued and
tried to sell them
that didn't work out there.
I will say one thing,
because I don't
want to get away without
saying anything embarrassing.
I had a column for Rolling
Stone for a little while
in the early '80s and talked
about technology and everything
from television and
things like that.
And I was reporting on the
brand-new channel called
the Weather Channel, which I
thought would be a total flop,
it would never last.
And the headline was,
"When it rains, it pours."
[LAUGHTER]
So I've gotten
some things wrong.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Yes, but what
you weren't thinking of then
was the number of
people who were
willing to equip vans with
videos and chase tornadoes.
STEVEN LEVY: Yeah.
That was before that.
RICHARD GRINGAS:
The Weather Channel
is hardly about the
weather anymore,
except as a meta for a story.
STEVEN LEVY: Right.
STACIE CHAN: Steven, you said
when you were a journalist,
you were always sort
of the outside--
STEVEN LEVY: When
I was a journalist?
STACIE CHAN: Well, you work for
Medium now, so it's different.
It's different.
And you said when
you joined Medium,
you were excited to
now be an insider.
STEVEN LEVY: Right.
STACIE CHAN: But as you said
your background is still
editorial, you're
still a journalist.
What insights are you
providing the product managers,
the engineers that you
don't think they quite
grasp because they don't
have the editorial background
that you have?
STEVEN LEVY: I think that's
one role that we do have,
the journalists who are working
at Medium, do provide there,
is that.
To say, hey, here's
what we did here.
This could have been better
if the product did x or y.
So for instance, the
thing I mentioned
before where we got a lot
of comments-- responses,
actually-- to the
David Weinberger story.
It surfaced some
ways that I felt
we could do responses better.
And I'm writing a thing on our
internal version of Medium,
called Hatch, with some lessons
that we can learn from that.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Steven.
I'm just wondering if more
media publications, kind
of like Backchannel,
you mentioned earlier,
will look into doing
sponsored content.
STEVEN LEVY: Right.
Well, I think, as I said,
we started it today.
And I think it's
one way that you
could do ads and get out of the
chase for just clicks, right?
One thing I'm proud of that
we have at Backchannel--
and I think this goes for a
lot of Medium in general--
is we don't lure people to the
page with misleading headlines.
Our bounce rate is super low.
But for an advertiser
point of view,
if they're just
looking at page view,
that's just as
worthwhile for them
as spending a long time on
a page reading something
and getting something
out of it there.
So in this case, if a sponsor
is going to be clever about it
and bring up something
which is inherently
interesting to people
but somehow illuminates
their product, their
field, it's a win-win.
And it helps us support, in
theory, the kind of journalism
that everyone loves in an era
where the business model still
is-- I think it's going to end,
but it still is bringing people
to a page and clicking on it.
RICHARD GRINGAS: What
are your favorite sources
of long-form tech journalism?
Just so we have it on the tape.
STEVEN LEVY: Well,
look, I have always
been a lover of Wired magazine
from the time it started.
I think Businessweek is doing
really good work these days.
I'm really encouraged that
a lot of the online sites,
which did not start
doing that, are
doing quality long-form there--
BuzzFeed, Business Insider.
Even though that might not be
the majority of their content,
they're investing in
long stories there.
And of course, sometimes
people like Clive Thompson,
who writes for the New
York Times Magazine.
There's lots of bylines
I always look for.
RICHARD GRINGAS:
And I last night
read a great 12,000 word article
on ISIS from The Atlantic
on my phone.
So it can be done.
STEVEN LEVY: Excellent.
RICHARD GRINGAS: I just want
to thank you for being with us.
This has been an
interesting hour,
and we just look forward to
your continued great writing
and insights.
We really appreciate it.
STEVEN LEVY: Thanks, Richard.
RICHARD GRINGAS: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]